this is giant mine in the Northwest
Territories of Canada there are
kilometers of tunnels under this rock
and chambers the size of city blocks
that have been hollowed out in the 20th
century more than 200,000 tons of gold
were extracted from the rock underneath
here at current prices that is somewhere
north of 8 billion US dollars worth of
gold there is a problem though that
mining also created more than 200,000
tons of toxic arsenic trioxide dust
that's enough to kill everyone on earth
several times over over the decades the
vast majority of it was stored in the
empty abandoned chambers left behind
after mining although some of it did get
out into the environment the mine closed
in 2004 when the gold ran out the mining
company went bankrupt and left the mess
for the government to clean up arsenic
trioxide has no scent no taste and it
dissolves in water oh and we're right
next to Yellowknife for the capital of
the Northwest Territories and next to
the 10th largest lake in the world
there's 237 thousand tons of arsenic
trioxide and they're currently stored in
the 14 underground chambers the plan is
to freeze the Chamber's we're freezing
the rock around the arsenic the arsenic
trioxide is a fine powder so it will
form a shell and eventually it will
freeze in and it will become a block
over time and that prevents water from
getting in and getting out and keeps the
arsenic trioxide contained so each
chamber of course is differently shaped
some are irregular shapes some are very
rectangular shapes so we want to freeze
ten meters beyond all boundaries of the
Chamber's both on the horizontal and the
vertical we're going to freeze at least
two minus five degrees Celsius the way
we're going to freeze it we're going to
use a technology called thermo siphon
technology and it's basically a
technology that uses the ambient air
temperature the cold air using a long
tube filled with carbon dioxide the
carbon dioxide when it's a gas it rises
up to the top of the tube and then if
the air is outside is colder it will
dissipate its heat turn to a liquid and
gravity will drop back down to the
bottom of the tube and there it can warm
up take the heat out of the ground and
it just continually cycles extracting
heat from the ground since we're in
Yellowknife north of 60 degrees latitude
it's colder above ground than it is
below ground for the majority of the
year
freezingly Arsenic doesn't make it less
toxic but it does make it impossible for
any water to seep in and then carry the
arsenic out and that was the mining
company's original solution using the
natural permafrost here and it might
have worked if they hadn't mined the
rock above it exposed the permafrost
layer to the elements and started to
melt it freezing should work but there
are skeptics and they do have a point
freezing requires constant upkeep this
dust is arguably worse than radioactive
waste there is no half-life here
it won't decay over time the dust will
be just as deadly in 10,000 a hundred
thousand or a million years so right now
there's there's nothing on the horizon
the freezing was deemed the best
technology for the arsenic trioxide so
where we will be funding research
indefinitely until a different solution
arises we have frozen one of the
chambers did what we called a freeze
optimization study we chose one of the
chambers we installed the thermo siphons
but we also installed some freezing
pipes filled with glycol to do what we
call an active freeze which would be
very similar to a hockey rink so based
on that study we determined that we
could use the passive technology which
is just the thermo siphons with the
carbon dioxide it just wasn't quite as
fast so it's gonna take a little bit
longer but the trade-offs are such that
we don't need to use power and it's a
lower maintenance over the longer term
so the remaining chambers will be frozen
when we start the remediation project it
could be as early as summer of 2020 but
more optimistically 2021 our last
estimate for the cost of the project was
934 million including the care and
maintenance phase that we're in right
now remediation that we'll go into in a
few years and then the long-term care
and maintenance this project has gotten
approval for a hundred years these days
countries in the developed world have
regulations that mean mining companies
shouldn't be able to do this we have
environmental impact studies and long
term plans and we have public scrutiny
of pretty much everything but we still
have to fix the mistakes of the past and
make sure that today's mining companies
can't just walk away from their legacies
thanks to everyone at the giant mine
remediation project pull down the
description for links about them and
about some of the histories I couldn't
fit into this video
you